Film Courage: Can you give us five filmmaking
tips for anyone who wants to make a movie?
Alex Munoz, Filmmaker and Founder of FYI Films:
First of all have a good screenplay. That’s
the most important thing. Have a good screenplay.
Number 2 - make sure you have the resources
to make the film. Don’t rush into making
the film unless you have the resources to
pay for the camera equipment, the locations,
and personnel.
The third one is have a really good producer
who knows that they are doing and be very,
very selection in who you hire.
So have a good script, have the resources
to make the film, hire a really, really good
producer, be polite and respectful and grateful
to every crew member and cast member. Very,
very, very important. One way you can show
gratitude is by feeding people well, keep
the morale up. And number five be open to
suggestions. I did a film with Rena Owen,
a really great actress from ONCE WERE WARRIORS.
She is on another plane…her acting…it’s
not mental…it’s the character. It’s
amazing. And so I would block things out and
she would say “I was thinking Oma would
do it this way.” And I said “Yes, you’re
right. Let’s do it.”
You have to be open. Don’t let your ego
get in the way of the process because that
will really mess you up. If you’re working
with an actress who has been acting for 30,
40 years and you’ve been directing for five
years, listen to that actress. So be open
to taking guidance or suggestions because
it will make you feel better.
Film Courage: What was the biggest mistake
you made in the beginning on a film set?
Alex: So I directed a a music video for a
company called Oil Factory and I got assigned
a cinematographer. I did not get to pick him.
I would ask him to do something and he would
not do it. I would say “Film it this way.”
And he would film it another way. And the
mistake I made was I didn’t stand up for
my vision. I said “Well I guess this is
what I have to do?” I was just out of film
school and I guess he’s a boor and sometimes
you have to work with boors.
The music video did not end up being a good
video. Why? Because he had no interest in
executing my vision. I don’t know what this
guy was about but the mistake I made was not
standing up for my vision in front of everybody.
I was too shy about it. I’ll never make
that mistake again.
The same thing…Well I wont talk about that.
But you have to defend your vision. You must
defend your vision. If there is someone that
is not helping you execute the vision, cut
them off. Because the video was a nightmare,
but I learned from it. That will never happen
again.